[Music]
did you hear the news we're going to the
internet wreckit-ralph to trailer is out
and it's one of the most magical things
we've ever seen don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a thumbs up now let's check out so
if you love the most about wreck-it
Ralph - relatable AF a movie about the
most popular things on the internet that
just means that it's going to be full of
endless cameos from some of our favorite
meme characters or so we hope wreck-it
Ralph too is already making some waves
online and we're totally here for it it
looks like this movie will be relatable
AF and we can great for the sassy quotes
eye rolls and all the giggles the
trailer definitely started this movie
off with a bang and by the looks of it
it's really going to be one of the most
relatable animated movies you'll ever
get to see Star Wars every comedy movie
gets a million times better after it
includes storm troopers and wreck-it
Ralph - is no exception
you can find the storm to bring in the
trailer when they chase penelope through
the so-called Internet land after all
storm super gifts are pretty popular so
if wreck-it Ralph too is on a mission to
break the Internet it's doing a pretty
good job by including some of the most
viral characters and memes ever you can
also catch the Millennium Falcon r2d2
x-wing Starfighter and TIE fighters
seriously this movie is definitely
already doing a lot of things right
controversial every viral movie has some
added controversial elements to it that
keep people talking this isn't
necessarily the right thing to do all
the time but it does keep the dialogue
going after all no publicity is bad
publicity in the trailer we've seen
Pocahontas but their skin appears to be
much more whitewashed than it should
which wasn't really accepted well by
some of the fans but this controversy
opens up a lot of debates about the fact
our original characters weren't
portrayed in the right way either
for example Metallica the original
Cantus actually had lighter stints
Cinderella turns mean Pocahontas and
Mulan aren't the only characters we see
in this trailer
seriously it's pretty impressive how
they were able to squeeze in so much
information and stories in just a few
minutes we also have the pleasure of
seeing Cinderella but she's not the
usual Cinderella you know the princess
that got her hair braided by the actual
birds is no more because she was totally
ready to attack an actual child with her
glass slipper ladies I'm a princess too
seriously this movie has so many strange
plot twists and we're here for them all
cameos the trailer might have just been
two minutes long but we've managed to
see so many pretty impressive cameos
we've already mentioned the
stormtroopers but you could also see
Iron Man passing through but one of the
best shout outs is definitely the one -
oh my Disney which is Walt Disney's
official blog and to make it even more
meta they blogged about their blog you
can probably spot at least a dozen of
the cameos in this trailer and they're
absolutely glorious so many gifts the
internet is already using so many gifts
from a single trailer it's pretty
incredible
we're already predicting that the
Cinderella point in her broken glass
slipper will be one of the most popular
reaction gifts ever we also have the one
where the whole Disney Princess Squad
turns up and Ironman casually passing
through the scene like it's nothing we
really have a feeling we'll be getting
so many reaction gifts from this movie
and let's be honest that's what people
want the most after all gifts make
things even more popular and they pretty
much live on forever
Twitter hype the best part about this
entire trailer was the reaction on
Twitter fans were using the hashtag
Ralph's rig to the Internet and it was
definitely a pretty popular hashtag some
of our favorite tweets include this one
from will Harrison who asks where we
were when we saw Cinderella try and
shank a child with a broken glass
slipper
we also giggled at da Marine foxes tweet
this person hasn't been this excited to
see a royal squad since Shrek we
understands buddy we understand were
pretty stoked to Marvel and Star Wars if
he wanted to see other Marvel characters
we
star wars characters you should
definitely watch this movie or at least
this trailer because that's exactly what
you'll find we also love that the Marvel
section of that internet land scene just
has a giant Iron Man shrine we have a
feeling that this was also a cheeky
giggle at the fact that Marvel's
infinity war was supposed to be the
biggest crossover ever it's really not
because wreck-it Ralph - pretty much
stole the show it's a sequel let's be
honest - didn't want a record Ralph's
sequel the first movie which came out in
2012 score is pretty high on Rotten
Tomatoes and it's been known to be
equally entertaining for both kids and
adults I don't know why are you so
freakishly annoying the first movie was
full of nostalgia and they really
managed to take it to the next level
with the second movie they managed to
crossover plenty of worlds everyone
wanted to see anyways that alone will
make fans from everywhere want to watch
it but we'll actually be watching for a
single reason and that is the Disney
Princesses United but one of the most
exciting things about this movie is
finally seen almost all Disney
Princesses in a single room the scene
got even more adorable when the
princesses became totally meta and
vanellope ask them if they're okay and
if she should call the police
if you think about it Disney Princesses
have some pretty messed up stories and
most of them had to go through a lot in
their lives but after all this time
we'll finally see all of them in the
same room and they'll be interacting
with each other yes that's all we really
wanted anyways and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]